canara saying do you think just because
I'm shy I can't make it canarsie
obviously shine genoa kana i think i
said this and I think lots of great
entrepreneurs are interest I think I you
know shows a relative term isn't it
because I've known really shy people of
coming to become a business owner and
they've been hugely successful and as
time goes by and they grow in confidence
their shyness sort of disappears I think
you never you never ever get carried
away with your own PR you always keep
your feet on the ground you always keep
that great sense of humility and you
really want to you know you want to be
true to your idea and the purpose that
you pursue in so I think can I they
honestly I think I think in this area to
shock on it can be quite a virtue and I
think with all these things is if you
are feeling particularly shot actually
another is another example you know when
you go up to these kind of meetups and
stuff like that Evan I will tell you now
I go and do loads of talks and stuff by
that if someone comes over to talk to me
I would always talk to them so if you're
a meet up and you want to kind of Zone
in on one person get wished in your head
saying that person wants to meet me
today and walk up to and just introduce
yourself and you lose nothing even if
you're going to never see that person
again you lose nothing but every time
you do that you lose a bit of your
showing us and you gain a bit more real
confidence and I would advocate all the
great entrepreneurs you and I follow
they're all super nice guys there really
are nice guys and gals and fundamentally
they all started where you have probably
started today and the good guys never
forget where they came from you know
it's reality we never forget where we
came from wheel starters aspiring
entrepreneurs with a dream with an idea
and an ambition and some of us kind of
lucky and the card played in our favor
but we never ever ever you know reality
lost that sense of shyness and I think
you know every looks like going to meet
an extrovert but again i'm sure in fact
had moments of shyness or lacking in
confidence I certainly did I've been to
places where I bet ready to go up and
introduce myself someone and sometimes
it's sort of either a little friend on
the shoulder or or someone in my inner
self just kicks me to say go and
introduce yourself those don't feel any
any shame just go up and over thumb and
then the more you do it the more you
practice the more confident you become
and you know can I you might be the next
you know Tony Robbins or something like
that within you all these guide to go
and do tedtalks and all these sort of
things if you look back at those guys 10
20 30 years ago they all started as
someone who's pretty shy somebody
probably lack confidence and any of
those people could be